okay so i know that's a bit weird and
you might feel
quite unfamiliar like you haven't done
much much set theory or that kind of
thing which is really what this is
dealing with
um so let that sit in your brain for a
little while but as promised i'm going
to give you another proof
for this same result which doesn't rely
on um
this kind of weird sort of trick here
it's not a proof by induction at all
it's actually a combinatorial proof
because
i kind of alluded to this um sort of
very quietly
as i was putting together this example
here there is another way of thinking
about this this is really about
choosing combinations right not
permutations where the order matters
these are sets where the order doesn't
matter so we're going to use our
ncr notation to try and come up with an
alternative proof for this okay
now the way i'm going to do this is i
think i'll have enough space here
i'm going to call this proof 2
combinatorial approach
all right how are we going to do this
let's just go back to this idea here of
a
b and c how did we come up with
the the number of total subsets here
right well i'm actually going to do this
kind of in reverse
i'm going to start with the smallest
subset you can make and then i'm going
to ramp up to the biggest subset that
you can make right
i'm no longer thinking of the
relationship between the two member set
and the three member set
i just want to go straight to three
members because then i can go straight
to k members i can generalize
in a different direction okay so for
starters
we had the the empty set is the smallest
subset you can make so i'm just going to
stick that over here then what you've
got is
the all of the subsets that have one
member so that's
a and then b and then c this is three of
those
right then i can think about how many
subsets
have two members in them well there's
the a and b
subset there's the b and c subset and
then there's the a
and c subset again there's three of
those
and then lastly i've got the subset
which includes
a and b and c that's the subset with
three that's the biggest subset i can
make so
i guess i'm going to put a circle
through there okay
now i want you to notice what's happened
in the way that we've
put these together right there's one
empty set
they are which color did i use i think i
used green
there are three of these subsets that
include just one member
there are also three of these subsets
that include two members
and then finally there is the one subset
that includes all of the members one and
then 3
and then 3 and then 1. doesn't this look
familiar these are the binomial
coefficients right i guess i would say
this is 3 choose 0
then this was three choose one
this was three choose two
and then the last one was three choose
three
okay now the reason why this is helpful
is because now we have an expression
for the number of subsets within a
k-member set
directly through combinatorial notation
through our binomial coefficients so i
can say
a k-member set
has let's just write it right
k c 0 plus k
c 1 plus k c 2
all the way up until k c
k subsets that's the way that i formed
these right i started with how many ways
are there to choose zero
how many ways are there to choose one
and then how many ways are there to
choose two
followed by or ended with how many ways
are there to choose three
right so this is just me generalizing
that to if i had k right
now i just need to work out what does
this thing add up to
uh k c 0 k c 1 k c 2 all the way up to k
c k now maybe you already have put
together like we've
we've proved this result from earlier on
via induction how do i get to this
result
how would you add up the sum of all
these terms without using
induction well we already have notation
for this right from
the binomial theorem which we actually
proved just a few days ago
the binomials theorem uh big capital
letters states
and if you have some binomial a to the
power a plus b
or raised to some integer power what do
you get and the answer is
sigma the sum of from 0
all the way up to n of and then here
comes the binomial coefficient
then you've got the term to do with a
and then you've got the term to do with
b right
now how do i take this binomial theorem
here by binomial theorem i think i can
just
squeeze it in if i write small enough
how do i use this to evaluate this right
well this kc0 kc1 kc2
it's here this is the actual part that
i'm interested in right
all i need is to set n equals k and then
this
r down here will match up from 0 all the
way up to k which is exactly what i want
us to do
but then you've got these other bits in
the binomial expansion right the a term
and the b
term now that's irrelevant to here right
i have no a's and b's
or rather than saying i have no a's and
b's i actually have
invisible a's and b's because these are
all kind of being multiplied
by one so therefore i just need to pick
a value for a and for b
that will make all of this turn into one
and it seems to me the most sensible
values for a and b
to choose will be one because watch what
happens
let uh firstly i said n equals k
and both a and b equal
one watch out this is so quick if you
blink
you're gonna miss it all right i'm gonna
go 1 plus 1
to the n equals the sum
from r equals 0 should have said k
instead of n because i already
did that substitution of uh k
c r and then this is one to the n k
i should say reflexes uh instincts
k minus r times one to the r
okay what's going to go go on here right
well i'm going to get this term here is
what i want
but everything over here is just going
to become these ones
up the top here right so they can be
disregarded more or less right
and then what do you get on the left
hand side you're going to get 2 to the k
i'm going to write that
on the right hand side that's the 2 to
the k which i got from here
and then what do i have on the left and
the answer is i've got the
expansion of this sigma notation it's k
c naught
plus k c 1 plus kc2
all the way up to k c
k and that's it like i already said that
this is the number of subsets there are
in a k member set it's 2 to the k
that's it full stop so uh perhaps you
would have thought like why didn't we do
it that way
in the first place and the answer is
well it's really important to be able to
have
number one multiple ways to look at
something because you gain
insight each time and number two like
one of the primary ways that we know
um that this method is right is because
induction
backs it up um it's sort of like a
mathematician's version of the
scientific method like we're repeating
this observation this
this experiment as it were except we are
using
deductive logic rather than instruments
and measurements
now fun final fact we know we first met
the binomial coefficients
years ago in pascal's triangle right
and what this tells us is that these are
all of the terms in
any single row of pascal's triangle now
that top number there represents what
row you're in
and then 0 1 2 all the way to k sort of
increments you along the row
so did you ever notice that the sum
of all of the numbers in any row of
pascal's triangle
will equal a power of 2 not just a power
of 2 the power of 2 of that row
for example the first row is just 1
that's 2 to the power of 0.
the second row adds up to 2 which is 2
to the power of 1.
the next one adds up to 4 which is 2
squared then you're going to get 8 which
is 2 cubed
16 which is 2 to the 4 and you can check
and convince yourself that the
last row i've drawn here is 32 which is
two to the five so
just one final example that i couldn't
resist showing you about how pascal's
triangle
despite how very simple it's constructed
it hides all these really wonderful and
profound
number relationships so i hope you
enjoyed that hope it made sense
think carefully even when you meet
something that looks quite unfamiliar
it will often be couched in language
that you can use you know examples for
example for instance numerical examples
are often a really good way
to make sense of what something is
asking you and then you can proceed
with the logic that you know from the
nature of proof